tight security outside the high court in
Islamabad a handful of supporters and
lawyers await the judgment
there is Jubilation and it's announced
Khan wanted to appeal against the three
years sentenced after being accused of
illegally selling gifts given to the
state during his five years in office
the spokesman for Khan's Pakistan Tariq
and self-party is cautiously optimistic
about what comes next first and foremost
it proves that the case originally
registered in the context of toshakana
was a fake and fraudulent case the
Chief Justice of the Islamabad high
court and the Chief Justice of the
Supreme Court are both and record to
have stated that in retrospect it
appears that the case at New Foundation
so this is coming from the Two Chief
justices he also said keeping Khan in
jail is unconstitutional and that his
legal team will continue to fight for
justice
legal experts say the court has no legal
basis to hold Khan indefinitely we
expect to use cases we believe that
there is no strength in the case that
may prolong his detention the Lahore and
Peshawar High courts have already passed
their judgments that if someone is
already under arrest he cannot be
rearrested unless there is permission
from the court
the Islamabad high court has suspended
Khan's sentence for corruption and
ordered his release however another
Court asked that he be kept in jail
until he is produced before the court in
another case pertaining to the official
secret Act
Hans supporters say there is a
deliberate attempt to keep Khan from
contesting the next elections due later
this year
and Pakistan's triggered political
history it is always difficult to
predict what comes next
but given Pakistan's worsening economic
crisis the situation remains untenable
and continued political instability does
not all go well for the country's future
Kamal Islamabad